[Music]
on this Saturday night Truth and
Reconciliation Canadians reflect on the
shameful Legacy of residential schools I
would encourage us to double our efforts
in advancing reconciliation plus the
efforts to confront residential school
denialists students attacking teachers
there's been a couple of cases of
weapons being brought into schools the
trend is is is definitely growing the
new warning about a terrifying
Trend American funding for Ukraine why
ke finds itself at the center of a fight
on Capitol Hill as us lawmakers race to
avoid a government
shutdown plus stealing the
show the New Vegas venue that moves in
mysterious
[Music]
ways global national with forign Asa
reporting tonight Je
simple a sea of orange across Canada
today as thousands gathered from coast
to coast to coast to Mark the national
day for Truth and Reconciliation raising
awareness about the Legacy and lasting
impact of Canada's residential school
system which caused generations of pain
and suffering for indigenous people
today those communities are reflecting
on the past while demanding a better
future good evening and thank you for
joining us the third annual national day
for Truth and Reconciliation was Mark
marked with marches songs and powwows
across Canada one of the largest events
was held in Ottawa where indigenous
Heritage and resilience took center
stage on Parliament Hill our David
Baxter was there and begins our coverage
tonight for decades these schools tried
to carry out their mission to kill the
Indian within the child we are here
today because they failed a sea of
orange shirts covers Parliament Hill as
Canadians are called to reflect on a
troubling part of our history the
residential school system it's something
Lori McDonald is all too familiar with
the abuse you suffered in there
especially sexual abuse you think um
it's your fault and that's what you're
led to believe so you don't go home
McDonald says it took him 60 years to
truly return home to the Enoch creation
now seeing all the orange shirts he
knows he isn't walking the healing Road
alone I may be on this journey of
healing and that healing will stop when
the Creator decides to take me home but
in the meantime I'm not walking alone on
this journey
anymore now indigenous musicians some of
the culture residential schools tried to
Stamp Out play outside the Parliament
building where those policies were
drafted a proud people who could not be
destroyed Canada's residential school
history was long suppressed so events
like this are a valuable tool for
descendants of those survivors to
connect with their past we're still um
reconnecting and and trying to find out
more about that history but really to
honor our ancestors and be proud of of
being an indigenous
person still thousands who went to
residential schools never got to have
their own families this cloth Bears the
name of over 4,000 children who never
came
home more children will be found and
their names will be added that's why you
see a lot of faes
a lot of parents a lot of children a lot
of Youth in the state that they're in
today is because a direct result of the
parents losing the
children the creation of this day is
part of the 94 calls to action from The
Truth and Reconciliation Commission but
more still needs to be done to heal
communities David Baxter Global News
Ottawa the Prime Minister marked the
national day for Truth and
Reconciliation at an event in
Saskatchewan
Justin Trudeau joined indigenous leaders
and community members in a March through
the town of larange in a speech he
referred to Canada as Turtle Island the
name used by some indigenous peoples and
he criticized those who are trying to
downplay the lasting impacts of
residential
schools and there are many who uh would
like us to Simply brush over the
past and pretend it didn't happen
because they feel that talking about
Truth and Reconciliation
marking this day somehow diminishes us
reconciliation is the action and the
responsibility of every single person
who lives today on Turtle
Island as the country remembers that
dark chapter of History the search for
answers continues an estimated
150,000 children were placed in schools
designed to erase their culture now so
far the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission has documented the deaths of
more than 4,000 indigenous children in
residential schools across Canada but it
estimates that 6,000 or more may have
died many First Nations are now trying
to locate their lost children not every
search has found remains and as Melissa
Ren explains that's fueling
misinformation it's a grim but necessary
task we want to share with the world
that we can confirm that
67 students passed away 40 unmarked
children
Graves shallow
Graves only large enough for the young
bodies to lay in the fetal position the
2015 Truth and Reconciliation Commission
final report warned Canada of thousands
of unmarked Graves at former residential
schools across the country the search to
find and identify those children now
underway regardless of the number of
children who died at residential school
kids shouldn't die at school there is no
one in Canada that sends their kid to
school today knowing that there's a
chance of them not coming home Brenda
gun is a mate lawyer and research
director at the national Center For
Truth and Reconciliation she says it
will be a yearslong process and not
every search will find remains this
summer minig gazia Nish shab first
nation in Manitoba hired a forensic team
to excavate 14 anomalies detected by
ground penetrating radar inside a church
basement there's always been stories
told from from elders and those who have
passed on about what happened here no
human remains were found this excavation
is but a small piece of a much larger
truth the results in Pine Creek are not
a means to deny the truths of those who
survived the residential school
experience and those who did not while
it was a relief to many in the community
it fueled residential school denialists
an interum report by Canada's special
interlocutor whose mandate is to help
communities as they navigate the search
for Graves highlighted this problem
Kimberly Murray wrote of denialists
entering the cam loops residential
school grave site in the middle of the
night carrying shovels they said they
wanted to see for themselves if children
were buried there the first nation has
had to hire Around the Clock security to
protect the site while the community
decides what to do with the children
buried there it's really unfortunate
that people use this moment and time
where we're still trying to gather exact
details to try to undermine the
experiences of survivors at residential
school gun says after the years of work
to identify and to rule out Graves
communities will need to decide whether
to leave them resting or to relocate
them Melissa Rin Global News
Winnipeg there is support for survivors
a 24-hour crisis line for anyone
experiencing pain or distress as a
result of their residential school
experience you can call toll-free and
speak in confidence at 1 1800 721
0066 a new poll shows most Canadians
believe more should be done to recognize
the legacy of residential schools that
data from ipsus shows about 70% of
Canadians believe governments and
individuals should do more but only
about 55% of Canadians believe there
will be meaningful reconciliation in
their lifetime to help with that healing
in 2015 The Truth and Reconciliation
Commission recommended 94 calls to
action and some of those steps focused
specifically on healthc care Katherine
Ward spoke to doctors to hear their
perspective on what progress is being
made as an indigenous woman I'm very
aware that every day that I'm in medical
school I'm working in a system that was
not made for me Kelsey Allen feels
Family Medicine could be her calling the
second-year medical student hopes to
eventually serve her community Halu
First Nation back home in newfinland
it's very important to me that as an
indigenous
doctor getting my medical education that
I do not come out on the other side of a
medical conveyor belt as another Western
Doctor Who is indigenous I want to be an
indigenous doctor who practices holistic
medicine and who acknowledges that
someone is more than just their symptoms
or their disease Dr Michael Dumont has
navigated that tension throughout his
career I know feel that I practice in my
in my work is is more of a two-e seeeing
approach um in the care that I provide
as a doctor there might be much more of
a um a culturally infused sort of
interaction you know the elders and the
traditional healers might be in the
visit with us we might be doing that in
our healing room rather than a in a
medical sort of office like the one I'm
in right now Dr Alica LaFontaine is a
past president of the Canadian Medical
Association he says representation is
improving I'm seeing more and more folks
going Specialties that are needed within
IND commities across the country but
barriers still exist especially for
students just starting their careers
many students face is that they're
forced to be not only in the learner
role but in the educator role for their
peers um you know when we're in
circumstances where you know we're being
taught um indigenous Health content in
our curriculum um oftentimes that
entails some really uncomfortable
questions Kelsey says she prioritizes
finding peace amidst the intensity of
the program
while remaining committed to being part
of a change she hopes will last for
Generations I think about hopefully in
three generations time we'll have so
much more capacity and we'll have
created a safe space that welcomes as
many indigenous people as want to be
doctors Katherine Ward Global News
Toronto every
child a little later on the program
we'll take a look at how indigenous
youth are commemorating truth at
reconciliation day and their efforts to
educate the Next Generation turning now
to a global news investigation looking
into reports of violence in Canadian
schools multiple teachers unions say
reports of student violence against
teachers are on the rise and without
proper supports they're worried that
problem will only get worse Naomi barale
reports death threats head injuries and
even poisoning that is just some of the
violence being reported by Canadian
teachers in recent months it's really
shocking multiple unions across the
country say the trend of student
violence against teachers has been
growing for the past 5 years but reach
new levels since students returned to
in-person classes a year ago there's
been a couple of cases of weapons being
brought into schools um the trend is is
definitely growing Bott says in the
first two weeks of the school year there
were already multiple reports of
teachers being stabbed with
pencils it's it's a lot of incidents and
it's it's uh very concerning several
regions across the country are also
experiencing a shortage of teachers the
president of the Ontario Secondary
School teachers Federation says as
violent incidents become more frequent
more teachers are leaving their
positions alog together we don't have a
teacher shortage we have a shortage of
good working conditions and that comes
back down to the safety in the schools
unions in four provinces Saskatchewan
Alberta Ontario and Nova Scotia tell
Global News funding is playing a big
role and why this kind of behavior is
worsening in Saskatchewan funding per
student has been declining for decades
while student enrollment keeps climbing
Bott says that without early support
it's tough to prevent violent acts in
the future although we're talking about
violence that is uh um happening from a
student to a teacher uh we really don't
feel that it is the student's fault
because in many of these cases um they
just haven't been provided the supports
necessary uh to to know how to to
express their emotions and express their
frustration in in an appropriate way
teacher Union reps fear the number of
incidents occurring is likely higher
than reported they said part of the
reason is that teachers assume reporting
won't lead to action or in some cases be
asked to show how they could have
prevented the violence Global News
reached out to all 13 provincial and
territorial education Ministries asking
for data on incident reports filed by
teachers experiencing violence only one
shared their data for the past year
Naomi bargel Global News down to the
wire coming up with hours to go until a
US Government shutdown the house passes
a spending bill without funding for
Ukraine all eyes are on the US Senate
tonight after the House of
Representatives voted in favor of
passing a stop Gap funding bill a key
step to avoiding a government shutdown
on this vote the yay are
335 the Nays are 9 91 2/3 being in the
affirmative the rules are suspended the
bill is passed and with that objection
the motion to reconsider is laid on the
table the 45-day short-term spending
resolution includes natural disaster
relief but no additional funding for
Ukraine a White House priority that's
opposed by a number of Republican
lawmakers with just hours to go before a
midnight deadline to fund the government
the bill still needs to pass the Senate
if it does not pass in time and the
government shuts down those in the
military will be forced to work without
pay and federal Works will face furlows
impacting programs and services that
thousands of Americans rely
on well Las Vegas is known to put on a
good show but the city is taking that
spectacle to a whole new level with the
inaugural concert at the
[Music]
sphere you too kicked off their 25 show
residency at the high-tech globe-shaped
venue inside inside the sphere an LED
screen wraps Halfway Around the audience
immersing the crowd that sphere cost
over $2 billion to build the venue's
exterior is also covered with
LEDs still ahead the view from the front
lines of the Wildfire fight in
[Music]
BC this year's historic Wildfire season
has been exhausting and punishing for
firefighters across Canada that fight is
the focus of our Global News current
affairs program the new reality which is
back with a new season and a new host
Carol and Jarvis has a preview of the
Premier episode with a rare look at the
front lines of the
firefight our crew spent three days with
BC Wildfire service this summer as they
persevered through a difficult season
with so many unknowns Adam Buchanan a
member of the BC Wildfire service and a
former fire investigator took
correspondent neug Gara to a Barren
landscape littered with charred trees
dried soil and seared holes he explained
that even though you can't see it fires
can still burn under ground to me this
looks like an animal bur it's not that
what are these holes when the fire moved
through here it consumed the stump and
also burnt all the roots and so the fire
will not just consume everything on top
like we can see but it also moves its
way and finds whatever vegetation is
available to burn underneath and so when
we're putting this out it takes a lot
longer because we can't just spray water
on the top we have to come and check
these and and this could still be
burning 10 12 15 ft down any one of
these routes that we're looking at wow
so we were deemed safe to come to this
area how did we know that there wouldn't
be a hot spot the only way to know for
sure is to get in there with our hands
feel it see if it's hot and if it is
then spend some time to make sure we put
it out in our program we also learn
about how the acceleration of climate
change is amplifying the length and
severity of fire Seasons experts are
calling for fire mitigation techniques
such as prescribed burning to be
significantly increased to hear more
about those strategies and the fire
fight watch the season premiere of the
new reality tonight at 7 on global
Carolyn Jarvis Global
News up next indigenous children reflect
on a dark past and look to a brighter
future
[Music]
work is now underway in British Columbia
to re-erect a memorial totem pole that
was taken without the first nation's
consent nearly a century ago the 11
meter pole was returned from the
national museum of Scotland yesterday
it's expected to take several days to
re-erect that Community is hoping to use
the totem pole as an educational tool
for generations to come AR Neu Gara
spent time with some of Nisa nation's
youth on this Truth and Reconciliation
day as the community looks forward to
what they hope is a brighter
[Applause]
future it can't be emphasized enough
every
every the message behind a movement with
so much meaning for these students and
teachers of Nisa Elementary Secondary
School resonate deeply forette McMillan
it lifts me up it lifts my heart up
because I'm a Indian day school survivor
the Nisa language teacher says seeing
these children walk with such honor
pride and joy helps deliver a message to
her inner child don't give up There's
Hope in the future I have attended this
school myself from kindergarten to grade
12 and I went to grade one in this exact
same classroom where I'm teaching grade
one for Lena Griffin on this National
Truth and Reconciliation day she's
thinking of her relatives who went to
residential school and her mother she
was in a TB Hospital which unfortunately
was the same the same abuse Griffin
believes creating a safe space for
children today doesn't mean shielding
them from honest conversations about the
historic and present day effects of the
institutions of assimilation they know
that healing needs to happen and when we
include them in those conversations
that's when it starts to happen my and
something kind of
like yeah your Oley and your gig they
both went and what happened to that
orange shirt J do you remember it been
taken away and never given back it was
taken away and never given back why why
that's a very good question why they're
exploring the big question of why
Phyllis webad founder of orange shirt
day had hers taken away every child M
sit up tall and proud and when we
breathe in we're going to
[Music]
say I am a good person I am a good as
these children are constantly reminded
of their value I love you very much Nea
Global News Nisa
nation that future is looking bright
that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Jeff simple thanks
for watching we leave you tonight with
more from Canada's national ceremony on
this day of Truth and Reconciliation
which included a banner with the names
of thousands of kids who never made it
home from residential
schools